kate enquête dans aujourd'hui à paris
par le tsunami
je voulais faire en allant d'extérieur
en disant bas ça va être sympa ces mini
c'est la porte activités on peut
l'emmener non bah non il n'ya plus
quasiment toute la journée donc je vais
tourner en studio là je tourne c'est le
soir voyant fin de journée je vais
tourner tout ça en studio rond se ferait
un truc en extérieur très prochainement
pour l'instant eh bien on va entrer à la
maison au chaud on va éviter la pluie et
regarder ipad mini est très pratique
parce que en réalité qui tient dans la
poche
voilà juste là dans la poche c'est
pratique c'est de la forte activité on
peut l'emmener partout mais on va
regarder ça bien au chaud à la maison
voulait un ipad vous voulez changer d'
ipad vous voulez acheter un ipad vous
vous posez la question de l'ipad mini
mais qu'est ce que je vais faire d'un
ipad mini un ipad mini oui mais pour
quoi faire cette question peut paraître
assez simple en fait vous allez voir
qu'elle est très compliqué qu'est-ce
qu'on va venir faire d'un ipad mini
alors il faut resituer un petit peu la
gamme de tous les ipad vous avez cette
année l'ipad mini vous avez l'ipad 9,2
neuvième génération qui est juste là qui
a été présentée également vous avez ipad
r qui était présentée l'année dernière
puis vous avez ri pak trop qui était
présentée plus tôt en début d année
voilà pour le line up des ipad 4 ipad
chaque ipad est vraiment précis dans sa
catégorie l'ipad 2 9e génération c'est
l'ipad pour tenir des buts et on a un
peu moins de 400 euros c'est l'ipad pour
les débutants et savait pas cher mais
malgré tout avec un grand écran donc
avec les usages de l'ipad l'ipad r c'est
l'intermédiaire bien évidemment on est
sur le haut de gamme on est sur un très
bas l'ipad on a eu beaucoup de
performances et on comprendra qu'on peut
même venir le transformer en petit
ordinateur grâce aux smart collector et
puis enfin vous avez l'ipad pro avec
aujourd'hui en tout cas cette année en
2021 et bien la puce m à l'intérieur
beaucoup de performances du pro motion
on peut le transformer en petit
ordinateur grâce aux smart connector et
puis surtout avec la performance que
vous avez intérieur et puis est revenu
en 2021 l'ipad mini de sixième
génération un petit ipad avec un écran
de 8,3 pouces et cet ipad mini et bien
je trouve qu'il a du mal à dire trouver
sa place dans la gamme alors on comprend
on comprend réellement qu'on peut venir
faire avec un ipad mini on peut venir
faire plein de choses à regarder des
films des séries on a un écran qui est
très sympa de bonne qualité c'est du
liquid retina cdu elle cédait si ya pas
deux arrêts dont un écran canton
rafraîchissement de 60 r c'est pas du
120ème donc sur gimme
rappaz le plus loin mais on a malgré
tout un très joli ipad dont la touch
heidi qui est juste en haut ici vous
posez votre doigt sa déverrouille c'est
pratique c'est bien alors cet ipad il
est très bien il est très bien conçue
très bien fabriquer vous avez la puce à
15 bionique beaucoup de performances au
niveau graphique au niveau du calcul ça
ira parfaitement bien vous avez du wifi
6 on a une version wifi uniquement avec
le wii fit si on également une version
avec de la 5 gr je vous resituer le
tarif vous allez voir que c'est pas si
évident que ça on à ipad ios 15 ici
c'est très bien très belle expérience
mais ça pourrait être perfectible sur un
écran de cette taille qui peut paraître
petit pour un ipad même si pour un
smartphone c'est très grand il ya 3
pouces l'écran est super vous avez du
trou tonnes vous avez une gamme de
couleurs p3 alors un écran qui paraît
extrêmement extrêmement lumineux un là
je suis à 510 maximum à l'intérieur tout
de suite ça ira bien mais si vous allez
en extérieur et qu'il ya beaucoup de
lumière ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui je peux vous l'assurer ça
sera pas parfait des haut parleurs
stéréo mais qui sont également
perfectible vous allez voir que c'est
pas extrêmement évident côté caméra ce
plutôt bien bosser vous avez un ultra
grand-angle à l'avant je vous montre une
fois de plus c'est super intéressant
pour de la visioconférence et une caméra
grand angle à l'arrière de 12 mégapixels
qui rend très bien également pour venir
c'était les documents mais guère mieux
mais moi je vais commencer par vous
montrer les points un peu négatif pour
se taille pas dès lors il a plein plein
plein plein de points positifs c'est une
très très belle machine très bien réussi
très bien conçu par apple apple
travaille toujours très très bien mais
il ya des trucs qui a regardé on va
enlever le smartphone lieu où vous avez
là et on va enlever la pulp and see il
reviendra dans quelques instants sont
des accessoires qui sont je veux pas
dire indispensable mais très pratique
ici parce qu'on peut venir l'utiliser
sans alors la première chose que vous
avez à voir et bien c'est à regarder ici
ce qu'ils ont complètement retravaillée
au niveau du design c'est bien vous avez
touch heidi sur le dessus qui déroule
bien pratique ça ça ne va bien et les
boutons de volume qui sont arrivés ici
alors le truc qui est sympa lorsque vous
le prenez comme ça vous posez votre
doigt vous déverrouillez facilement en
mode portrait vous mettez en mode
paysage de la même manière vous
enregistre à nos doigts d'ailleurs ils
vous invitent à venir le faire donc ça
c'est vachement bien vous posez votre
doigt vous déverrouillez ça ne va bien
maintenant ce qu'il va beaucoup moins
c'est que lorsque je le tiens comme ça
et bien voyez mes boutons de volume sont
là donc pour le monter c'est le bouton
sur le haut et pour le bcc le bouton sur
le bas et là où ils sont malins chez
apple regarder ainsi je vais mais dans
l'autre sens c'est là où on s'y perd un
petit peu le bouton qui me servent à
baisser le son bain servira à monter
leçons parce qu'il va venir basés ici
sur votre position de tenue et pas
réellement sur le bout lui-même
maintenant le truc c'est que bien vous
ayez quatre grilles ici fin de chaque
côté pour vos haut-parleurs et bien en
réalité vous n'avez que des
haut-parleurs stéréo les haut parleurs
se situe en réalité au niveau des
grilles duo alors la grille du bas sert
à diffuser le son bien évidemment mais
tous leçon arrive d'en haut donc si vous
le tenez comme ça dans ce sens là ça ira
très bien et ça fonctionnera si
maintenant vous le prenez dans l'autre
sens et que vous le positionner comme ça
avec mes petits boutons de volume qui
sont situées sur le bas et bien je viens
bloqué mais haut parleurs qui situe là
il faut vraiment venir le mettre dans
l'autre sens et venir tenir dans ce sens
là et là vous avez un truc qui marche
donc une fois de plus haut parleurs
situés là et l'a donc là vous pouvez
donc lorsque vous venez jouer à des jeux
vidéo ça est exactement la même chose
hop là regardez j'ai appuyé gelé et un
faut faire attention parce que ces
petits boutons ils sont pratiques mais
pas toujours parce que on a facilement
fait devenir les tags lorsque vous le
tenez comme ça donc il faut faire gaffe
à pas venir l'éteindre et petits trucs
voyez des petites bidouilles maintenant
il ya un truc ne trouve pas génial
génial et ça c'est purement un logiciel
célia et pas des os sur votre ipad et
bien vous avez quand même alors ça
dérange ramoin comme ça en format
portrait qu'en format paysage vous avez
des banques qui sont un petit peu lâche
sur le côté tout vous icône elles sont
toutes mini mini mini mini mini mini en
bas on est sur un ipad mini les icônes
son mini c'est normal mais si vous le
passez au format paysage vous avez quand
même ici des grandes bandes sur le côté
et autant ça me dérangera mois serait
pas qu'un peu plus grand parce que mes
icônes seront plus grand des pilules je
le verrais davantage ici je trouve que
c'est un peu moins un peu moins pratique
et ça vient un petit peu me me poser
problème alors c'est du point de détail
on dirait on choisit un ipad mini ont
choisi la compacité il faut l'accepter
il faut le savoir maintenant il ya un
truc est vraiment génial qu'a fait apple
bien c'est qu'ils nous ont mis un bloc
de charge avec et bien oui alors que les
blocs de charges disparaissent
aujourd'hui des iphone bien vous en
avions ici qui inclut aussi dans votre
boîte avec votre ipad mini donc ça c'est
cool et ont plus de sa choses qui
arrivent vous avez de la recharge et si
en usb ces élus sbc c'est très pratique
pour quoi et bien parce que vous allez
pouvoir utiliser l'usb c'est pour
différents accessoires déjà brancher un
disque dur externe si vous souhaitez
faire un peu de sauvegarde récupère les
données transférées compagnie ça c'est
vachement bien branché également des
accessoires et en existe plein ça permet
donc de rendre cet ipad plus compatibles
d'aller plus loin en termes de
connectivité alors ça vous l'avez
aujourd'hui avec son ipad là on
reparlera de l'ipad 2 9e génération
quelques temps qui lui par contre n'a
que du lightning alors ça vous met ces
quelques jours on or pas d'ailleurs
abonnez vous pour être informé il vous
saurez tout lorsqu'on parlera de cet
ipad là et 2 un autre sujet le petit
bouton rouge est en bas si les rouches
et vous n'êtes pas abonné puis actionnez
la cloche comme ça vous serez notifié
dès qu une prochaine vidéo rivera et ça
ça me plaît bien l'autre truc qui est
bien que ce ipad mini bah oui comme
c'est du mini pas forcément il tient à
une main c'est l'idée c'est ce que veut
faire appel ici un ipad mini vous le
prenez vous le tenez à une main alors je
viens quand même le tenir à demain
lorsque je joue à des jeux lorsque je
regarde des films et des séries il n'est
pas extrêmement lourd donc ça c'est bien
l'autre point qui est extrêmement bien
et très pratique je vous le disais c'est
le stylet vous avez un apple pensi de
deuxième génération qui vous permet de
faire tout ce qu'on peut faire avec un
appel pencil naviguer et griffonné
lorsque vous venez recherchez des choses
pouvaient venir les écrire ici alors bon
vous pouvez bien écrire ou très mal
écrire faire comme moi aux pois qui est
positif c'est que vous avez cette puce à
15 bio netbook tout ce qui va être
expérience de gaming et bien ça va tu
parti n'est un axe sa marche extrêmement
bien on pourrait regretter site pas voir
d'écran avec un taux de rafraîchissement
de 120 hertz est clair et surtout il
sait ce qui est vachement bien avec ipad
ios et que vous allez avoir des mises à
jour pendant longtemps c'est l'intérêt
d'apple c'est cet écosystème ce sont ces
mises à jour ipad ios ça marche
merveilleusement bien mais une fois de
plus attention vous allez pas tout faire
avec ici bien que ce soit un ipad bien
vous ayez de la performance c'est petit
et si vous voulez vous dire ben tiens je
veux l'utiliser pour regarder à mes
rendez vous tiens je les en mobilité
avec moi c'est l'idée ici avec un un
format comme celui-là léger compact
c'est la mobilité mais vous n'avez pas
passé à des heures à faire du petit
montage vidéo ni de l'infographie ni du
graphisme du dessin parce qu'à un moment
vous allez vous fatiguer les yeux on a
besoin d'une tablette un peu plus grande
bo qui trouva complètement sa place dans
un écosystème or je peux l'imaginer va
très très bien su utiliser en complément
d'un iphone est ce de deuxième
génération et pas 2 apporte beaucoup de
solutions en termes de productivité donc
pouvoir faire aussi des conférences
parce que oui vous avez le cadre centre
et grâce à cette caméra ultra
grand-angle que vous avez à l'avant ce
qui est génial et si c'est que quel que
soit l'endroit où je me situe eh bien ma
caméra me suis voyez alors je peux me
déplacer je peux me recule et je peux
même carrément me mettre là elle vient
me suivre elle reconnaît mon visage donc
cette fonctionnalité de cadre à centrer
c'est vraiment super bien alors là je
vous demande sur facetime et vous l'avez
également sur zone mais sur toutes vos
applications de conférences pour venir
parler et partager directement avec vos
amis entrent dans le cadre professionnel
dans le cadre familial donc la notion de
productivité d'entreprise on l'a mais
vous n'allez pas passer des heures sur
un tableur sur un petit écran sans quoi
vous allez vous fatiguer les yeux de
plus et je vous disais vous n'allez pas
brancher un clavier puisque vous n'avez
pas de smartphone hector alors vous
pourrez faire les choses grâce au
bluetooth mais pas au-delà donc
l'utiliser comme une liseuse c'est
parfait l'utiliser pour du gaming c'est
pas mal parce que vous avez la
performance mais vous n'avez pas un taux
de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz donc
c'est pas ici qu'on aura expérience à
plus d'1 go l'utiliser pour regarder des
films et des séries bien évidemment mais
c'est là où le bât blesse c'est le tarif
il coûte en version 64 giga de stockage
et uniquement en wifi
559 euros et si vous le voulez en
version 5 g 729 euros et si vous montez
en 256 giga de stockage vous êtes à 729
euros en version wi fi et 899 euros en
version 5 g et c'est pas tout si vous
voulez rajouter la pulp and s'il est
bien fort ajouter 135 euros et le
smartphone you vous avez la 65 euros ce
qui fait que si je pars sur la plus
petite config l'ipad mini de sixième
génération plus l'apple pencil plus le
smartphone you je suis à
759 euros et lorsque vous savez qu'un
ipad r coûte 669 euros
je suis pas sûr que ça vaille le quan ho
clairement ici sa taille parle vous
n'allez pas l'utiliser pour venir faire
du montage vidéo vous ne serez pas du
graphisme poussez vous n'avez pas faire
de la productivité longtemps avec des
tableurs vous allez vous flinguer les
yeux vous n'allez pas destinée pendant
très longtemps parce que vous avez un
petit écran et puis arrivera un moment
où c'est bien sympa il vole stylet mais
sur un petit écran comme ça à ça le fera
pas trop on pourrait se dire il est
petit donc les destinées à des enfants
pour me regarder des films des séries
c'est vachement bien tant que première
tablette il est tout petit et il a de la
performance mais attendez est ce que je
vais mettre 559 euros pour que mon fils
est une petite tablette moi je le ferai
pas parce que c'est cher vous trouverez
des tablettes moins cher vous trouverez
notamment on aille pas de neuvième
génération qui sera en dessous des 400
euros et vous serez chez apple avec de
la performance mais ça on en reparle si
quelques jours donc cette tablette elle
est très nicher elle est destinée à très
peu de personnes à des personnes qui
veulent vraiment une petite tablette
signée apple qui veulent être dans
l'écosystème apple qui ont les moyens de
le faire parce que malgré tout ça reste
un budget pour tout petit écran comme ça
attention ne me faites pas dire ce que
j'ai pas dis c'est une superbe machine
mais elle est petite 8,3 pousse certains
adoreront d'autres n'ont d'ailleurs dit
moi si c'est votre cas en bas en
commentaire moi je les aime bien mais je
n'ai pas utilisé pourquoi parce que
trois petites j'ai utilisé pour regarder
des films des séries d'accord mais
j'irai guère plus loin autant l'écran et
une qualité autant l'audio est un peu
trop sur le médium je reste un peu sur
ma faim sur ce produit je trouve
intéressant je trouve bien réussi je
trouve très beau vous avez un dos avec
un aluminium brossé très belle finition
nouveau design qui est extrêmement
efficace il ya plein de couleurs qui
sont très sympas chez apple mais c'est
pas un produit qui a fait pour moi
peut-être est-il fait pour vous
d'ailleurs dites le moi en bas en
commentaire allez on s'embrasse a très
vite ciao
[Musique]